Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Getting Over It with Bennett Foddy
I am at
the bucket and I'm not even gonna acknowledge the fact that there's a snake there 'cause I don't care
*mocking Bennett*
DUUUH
I'LL FEEL BADIF I WIN!
What, I'll feel good if I LOSE?!
Oh god...
Come on...
ughhhhh
No, not that way definitely not that way
That's not gonna work
Okay... and...
Oh n-NOOOOOOoOooOOOoooOOOOoOoo
Everything's fine
No... oh man, this doesn't like me
Nope
There we go
No, oh, that's too much swing swung okay, just enough swing swung oh
boy, I don't remember.
Is it a launch across here??
Is it a launch across here? I can't remember - I can't remember what it is. I'm wracking my brain, but nothing's coming up
I'm drawing up ... to a carton of
ssspoiled milk... that's the only thing that's in my brain right now.
Ohhhh, the inner machinations of my mind are an enigma here we go
(YEE)
Okay alright, so this is as far as I've come
I've never been able to get up this hill and I don't think it's something you can take slowly. You kind of just gotta
wangle-dangle it and
hope and if you fall, I gotta like push to get to the wood part
Let's see my only hope
BENNETT: Have you thought about who you are in this? Are you the man in the pot
Diogenes..?
Are you his hand? Are you the top of his hammer?
MARK: nO
BENNETT: I think not.
Where your hand moves the hammer may not follow
nor the man, nor the man's hand
In this, you are his will, his intent, the embodied resolve in his uphill ascent.
MARK: No no no no no no no no no no no no no
Almost had it. Oh, I was so close. I was right there. I was right there. Oh, I was right there
Oh, I was right there come on. No. I don't want to go in the hill anymore. That's it
That's it, gotta bite! Gotta get a bite to it, gotta get a real bite. Oh wrangle-dangle bite, ooh
Don't wangle my dangle! You bite my why no no nO
nOOOOOOLULULULULUH
No-
nope
no why am I doing that now what what is happening?
no?
Nuuuu
nuuuu
Nuuu, nooo, it's getting real wangly-dangly right now. I swear that it creeps
the mouse sensitivity up like an asshole
I swear it knew Oh cuz now it's nice and easy no it's not it is not easy
uuuuu
I'm so scared. I'm so scared
I'm so scared. I can't get on the bucket
I can't get on-
no whY WHY WHYYY
WHAT THE F**K WAS THAAAAAAAA--
WHAT THE F**K. WAS. THAT?!
WHAT THE F**K WAS THAAAT?
*Mark fades into the void*
What the hell happened? :(
F**king criminy! I was so cloooose!
I was at the end :(
F**king criminy
Alright... everybody just gimme... gimme some...
Just some quiet and...
quiet contemplation.
This... is the last obstacle.
ahhh...
ah
aH
AH
OH
HOOOOOO
*suggestive celebration*
*laughter of success*
*happy Mark :)*
*more happy Mark noises*
*more suggestive celebration*
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh, my god, don't f**k it up
BENNETT: You conquered the ice cliff. The platforms, church and the rectory, the living room and the factory
the playground and the construction site, the granite rocks, and the lakeside
You've learned to hike.
There's no way left to go but up.
In a moment, I'll shut up, but let me say
I'm glad you came.
MARK: Okay, well if I f**k this up, then I'm probably just gonna throw my computer out of the window and jump off a bridge but
I'm not gonna lie
I know this is the end and I'm very terrified because I
have a funny feeling I will find a way to screw this up. I know this is the end.
Nnnno, n- see, see, see, see?
I know I'm gonna find a way to f**k it up
I know I'm gonna find a way to f**k it up, and I'm not gonna f**k it up. I'm not
I'm not gonna f**k it up because I know, I know beyond ALL know...
Man I am just, so nervous. I am just a bundle of f**king nerves right now
I'm a bundle o' nerves 'cause I know this is
Oh, see?! JhuwoOHHHH see do you see do you see oh my goooOooOoOooOooDDDD
*deep breaths Mark*
I need to calm down or I'm gonna lose everything. I will lose everything. I've done this a million times
It just looks different, but I've done this before
ye
Done it many, many, many times before
Oh, I'm stuck. HeeEEEE
that's an excitable, excitable man
Just gotta be sooo cautious here.
I am
I am full... of spunk
D:
ugH WHY? gyooOHHHH
My god. Oh my god. Oh my god. I
Why did that happen oh my god?
Why did that happen iyiee iyiee fear fear fear
fear fear fear fear fear
FEEEEAR FEEAR fear fear
Fear is the only emotion in my mind. Fear is the only emotion in my mind oh
Jeezums -- NO WHY?! No, nohoho!
oh my gOD I am afraiiiid
I'm so scared. I am right here, and my nerves are just making me fuck it all up
I've done this so many times. This is so easy
Yeah, no.
Oh my god. What is happening to me? I -- my hand is shaking SO badly. I don't know what that was
No - see - oh my god. Oh my goodness gracious, I cannot for the life of me [breathes]
Can't fffor the life of me calm down, I cannot calm down.
I am SO nervous.
No god, hooooh no
I'm just... oh my god. I need to- hah god. I'm just so f**king nervous. I'm so f**king nervous
I don't know why! I don't want to f**k it up!
aAAAAAA
eAAAAGH
so unbelievably nervous.
I don't know why, I don't understand why, I don't KNOW why.
'Kay, I'm right here. This is the end. I know.
Just gently... I've done this a million times. It's the same thing as I've always seen.
Same thing, a million times. (Been through this a million times...)
Just nice and relaxed...
There we go
Get stuck a little bit, but I can get out of that
Come on you
Laaaast one.
Okay
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh!
hah hah h a h h a h
*suggestive celebration*
Where am I? oh! hello hi? hello? Hi?
Oh oh oh oh oh oh
BENNETT:  I dedicate this game to you, the one who came this far.
I give it to you with all my love.
MARK: Oh, I still don't like you. Still don't like you. Still don't like you aaaat aaall.
At all
[Markigasp]
*stunned but happy Mark*
*celebrations*
:,D
DOOH
BENNETT: (singing) "I'm goin' down the road feelin' bad..."
AAAAAAH
"I'm going down this road feelin' bad..." MARK: YEA-HAH!
And I ain't gon' be treated this a-way..."
MARK: Yes! BENNETT: (singing) "I'm goin' where the chill wind never blows..."
"Yeah, I'm goin' where that chill wind never blows..."
MARK: Oh hoh, man! BENNET: I'm goin' where the chill wind never blows~
and I ain't gon' be treated this a-way."
BENNETT: "I'm goin' where the climate suits my cold..."
"Well, I'm goin' where my cauldrons never cold..."
"I'm going where the climate suits my cold
And I ain't gon' be treated this a-way."
Hoh...
BENNETT: (singing) "I'm goin' down this road feeling bad..."
"Lord, I'm going down this road feelin' bad..."
"I'm going down this road feelin' bad.
And I ain't gon' be treated thisaway, way, way, way, way..."
Ah....
Hoh...
Oh
Oh no
Aw man.
Clear time: one hour 18 minutes. That is not the clear time. Clear time's like 26 hours. Oh my god
I did it welcome to the top of the mountain if you're alone you can come inside and say hello
I solemnly swear that I'm not recording a stream in this and I understand that though only those who have climbed are welcome
I'm not gonna show you guys it. I will show you me reacting to it
If that's even appropriate, but this is ...
*Happy Markimoo giggles*
Oh
Oh man
This is worth it yeah, I can't tell you guys what it is.
I can't. I will make that a complete secret, but it's worth it
It's very worth it.
And there you have it.
Sorry, I can't show you guys what it is
You have to climb to the top yourself, and I know there's some people that have spoiled it, but
there's something to the integrity of it, like, really. It's a weird thing. There - there really is something to that
so...
I did it (yaaay mark!!)
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Thank you everybody for being here <3
I'm so happy that you joined me, and, uh, I don't think I'll ever try this again
But I do want to play more difficult games. If you guys know more difficult games put them in the comments below
It doesn't matter how much rage I have, there is that feeling of satisfaction
I actually am a person that loves to start over
I start over in everything I do when I'm playing, like "Oxygen Not Included." I start over all the time with better strategies
I just love starting over with more knowledge and experience.
Same game, more experience. Like, there's something magical about that
Sometimes, I wish I could new game + the YouTube thing, but man. It's just such a... such an amazing thing, so -
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Thank you for enjoying alongside me as I raged my way to the top of the mountain, and as always... I will see YOU...
in the next video! Buh-bye!
Subtitles by Can TASKIN, Florida Day and Autumn Cat